(Music)
I want you to publish this.
You're finally gonna let me
publish one of your poems?
But you can't print my name.
Why not?
Because my father doesn't
approve of women publishing.
(Music)
Hailee Steinfeld:
What's so incredible about
playing a person that existed lifetimes ago
Hailee Steinfeld:
is her story and her voice is so
relatable in what she faces
everyday as a young woman.
I do not approve of a woman
seeking a literary reputation!
Alena Smith:
Woman in a certain sense were
property.
You will tend to your duties as
your mother does.
Alena Smith:
And we're trying to find the
uncanny residences between the
1850's and today.
In this house what matters is
what your father wants.
We're not doing a bio pic of
Emily Dickinson in any kinda
straight forward sense.
Alena Smith:
We are doing our own poetic
interpretation of Emily Dickinson.
Alena Smith:
To create a modern and feminist
retelling of her life.
Mrs. Dickinson:
You're gonna make a good house
wife one day Emily Dickinson.
It's high time for you to get a
husband.
Emily has this need for
intellectual stimulation
Ella Hunt:
and to be seen as the equal of
men.
Why won't you marry me?
I'm not gonna marry anyone.
Hailee Steinfeld:
She believe in herself.
She was a practical woman who
Hailee Steinfeld:
was completely aware of her
gifts.
Why can't I go to the college?
Look, an education prepares one
for a career.
And a career of a woman is in
the home.
Hailee Steinfeld:
Even though she was told that
her work
will never see the light of
day.
Hailee Steinfeld:
That never stopped her.
She kept going.
It's not up to my father to
decide my fate.
And it's not up to you.
Hailee Steinfeld:
Knowing that her way with words
have had an impact
on so many people around the
world
is incredibly inspirational.
And it's been wonderful to bring
that to life.
(Music)